hello everyone let's begin our guided
tour welcome to the Museum of museums
museums have been a part of human
history for over 2,000 years but they
weren't always like the ones we visit
today the history of museums is far
older and much stranger than you might
imagine
we'll start over here in the Greek wing
our word museum comes from the Greek
Museum temples built for the muses the
goddesses of the Arts and the sciences
supplicants asked the muses to keep
watch over academics and grant ingenuity
to those they deemed worthy the temples
were filled with offerings of sculptures
mosaics complex scientific apparatus 'as
poetic and literary inscriptions and any
other tribute that would demonstrate
immortals worthiness for divine
inspiration we have arrived at the
Mesopotamian wing the first museum was
created in 530 BC in what is now Iraq
and the first curator was actually a
princess anna gaulden anna started to
collect and house
Mesopotamian antiquities in a geek par
her house when archaeologists excavated
the area they discovered dozens of
artifacts neatly arranged in rows with
clay labels written in three languages
she must have had interesting parties
the tradition of collecting and
displaying intriguing items began to be
mimicked as you can see here in the
Roman Empire winged treasure houses of
politicians and generals were filled
with the spoils of war and Royal
menagerie this played exotic animals to
the public on special occasions like a
gladiator
as you can see we have a lion here and a
gladiator and well the janitor ought to
be in this wing clearly moving on very
long the next step in the evolution of
museums occurred in the Renaissance when
the study of the natural world was once
again encouraged after almost a
millennium of Western ignorance
curiosity cabinets also referred to as
wonder commerce were collections of
objects that acted as a kind of physical
encyclopedia showcasing artifacts just
step into the Wardrobe here there you go
mind the coats and we'll tour olá worms
cabinet one of the most notable wonder
comers belonged to a wealthy 17th
century naturalist antiquarian and
physician ola worm Ola worm collected
natural specimens human skeletons
ancient runic texts and artifacts from
the new world in other curiosity
cabinets you could find genetic
anomalies precious stones works of art
and religious and historic relics
oh my you might not want to touch that
these cabinets were private again often
in residences curated by their owners
rulers and aristocrats as well as
merchants and early scientists now who
here's a circus organ in the 1840s an
enterprising young showman named Phineas
T Barnum purchased some of the more
famous cabinets of curiosity from Europe
and started Barnum's American Museum in
New York City a spectacular hodgepodge
of zoo lecture hall wax museum theater
and freak show that was known for its
eclectic residents such as bears
elephants acrobats Giants Siamese twins
a Fiji mermaid and a bearded lady along
with a host of modern machinery and
scientific instruments museums open to
the public are a relatively new
phenomenon before Barnum the first
public museums were only accessible by
the upper and middle classes and
only on certain days visitors would have
to apply to visit the museum in writing
prior to admission and only small groups
could visit the museum each day the
Louvre famously allowed all members of
the public into the museum but only
three days a week in the 19th century
the museum as we know it began to take
shape institutions like the Smithsonian
were started so that objects could be
seen and studied not just locked away
American museums in particular
commissioned experiments and hired
explorers to seek out and retrieve
natural samples museums became centers
for scholarship and artistic and
scientific discovery this is often
called the museum age nowadays museums
are open to everybody
our centers of learning and research and
are turning into more hands-on
institutions but the question of who
gets to go is still relevant as ticket
prices can sometimes bar admission to
those future scholars artists and
targets of divine inspiration who can't
afford to satisfy their curiosity thank
you all for coming and please feel free
to stop by the gift shop of gift shops
on your way out